[Music]  ah  the highlands one of the purest places  on earth  hardly a foot has touched wait who the  hell  start okay roll call  donkey mcdonald's team jobson  pj beetroot  can i have your real name just that's  that one down there  william de beauvoir william oh  [Music]  i'll meet you at the campsite at 6pm  be careful we don't want to get lost in  the highlands there's danger everywhere  hello boys  they nearly killed us we got your  weapons  we're doomed to make a bomb  where's the explosion you have a whole  point of a bomb  master carlyle  i've never  [Music]  your generation you're always  complaining always saying you are the  victim [ __ ] off god damn it  we have to stop them sure what was super  high  you won't get away with this we always  do  let's finish  nothing ever happened in the highlands  [Music]  you